so pretty recently was considered
totally out of bounds to question
someone's patriotism because of
political difference in Washington that
was called McCarthyism and only the
lowest sort of people engaged in that
now it's completely par for the course
for people on the left to accuse you of
treason if you dare to distribute Joe
Biden in any way case in point Tulsi
gabbard who was a Democrat a former
sitting member of Congress challenged
the idea that it would be a good policy
for the United States to fight a hot war
with Russia for saying that and by the
way she speaks for the overwhelming
majority of Americans and making that
obvious point but for doing it members
of both parties called her a traitor
quote Tulsi gabbard is parroting false
Russian propaganda wrote Mitt Romney of
Utah her treasonous lies May well cost
lives
Keith Oberman who is ludicrous but still
live agreed he said Chelsea gabbard is a
quote Russian asset Who belongs in jail
now this kind of stuff flies around the
internet all day long and most people
just kind of shrug it off and keep
moving but Tulsi gabbard doesn't seem
like she's going to she's on the verge
side of taking legal action against both
Mitt Romney and Keith obermann we should
tell you you probably know Chelsea
gabbard is a U.S Army Reserve officer
she joins joins us tonight to explain
her decision congresswoman thanks so
much for coming on thanks Tucker um so
how do you plan to respond to this
uh well first of all let me let me say
that I I took an oath as you mentioned I
still serve in the US Army Reserves
today I'm a lieutenant colonel and 19
years ago when I enlisted in the
military I took an oath to support and
defend our constitution I took that very
same oath when I was elected to serve in
Congress where I served for eight years
Senator Mitt Romney has taken that oath
as has every other member of Congress
who has had the privilege of serving and
if Mitt Romney had read the Constitution
he would know that treason the crime
that he's accusing me of that is
punishable by death is so serious that
our Founders deemed it to be the only
crime worthy of being defined in our
Constitution and so the situation that
we're facing here is a very serious one
not not because it's about me but
because it has a much bigger impact on
our country when powerful and
influential people
basically threaten and intimidate people
into silence as Mitt Romney Keith
olberman and others are due doing
they're hoping to achieve that effect
that if anybody dares speak out against
the government that if anybody dares to
criticize whatever the the washed
permanent Washington establishment's
narrative is then you will be smeared as
a traitorous uh you know treasonous
traitor
um and frankly it also if Mitt Romney is
serious seriously believes that I have
committed treason
why hasn't he brought any evidence or
brought charges uh he clearly doesn't
care that there are any consequences or
as I mentioned he's just trying to
intimidate and Bully me and others into
silence let me ask a question so so Mitt
Romney famously dodged the war in
Vietnam he's a coward you serve in the
U.S military so you talk to people who
also serve and who might be called to
fight this war against Russia of the
people you know who are currently
serving the US military how many believe
that raising questions about whether or
war with Russia is a good idea
constitutes treason do a lot of your
fellow officers think what you said is
treasonous
not a single person that I know that
I've had the privilege of serving with
and even those who I don't know
personally who take this oath to support
and defend our constitution to be loyal
to our country wearing the uniform
knowing that we can be called to give
our lives in service to our country at
any time I'm confident in saying that
they would not agree with his
accusations yeah I'm not I'm not
surprised at all the people who actually
face the risk
understand we need the conversation so
how do you think you might react to this
uh we'll see we've sent out these cease
and desist letters to both Senator
Romney as well as Keith Olbermann and
frankly Tucker it's in the hopes that
they will recognize it's giving them the
opportunity to tell the American people
you know what on second thought we
understand how serious this crime of
treason is
will apologize and we'll make sure that
this some this doesn't happen again
because if we love our country we care
about our democracy we care about Free
Speech the last thing that anyone with a
platform should want to do is to create
this chilling effect where people are
afraid to express their views whether
they are mainstream or not whether they
are in line with those in power in
Washington or not this is America and we
all need to stand up and protect this
speech because today it's me tomorrow it
could be you yeah I mean you know
oberman's a sad husband who lives alone
with his cats But Mitt Romney is a
sitting U.S senator so I yes I hope that
you will join us with his response
because he needs to provide one I would
say Tulsi gabbard thanks so much looking
forward to it thank you subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight